the ota issue has not yet resulted in
litigation or any type of a union
grievance but there is a fight between
the nfl and the nfl pa that is still
happening the question of whether or not
players
will show up or not show up and the
dribs and drabs of teams
issuing statements saying they're not
going to be there again i'll believe it
when it doesn't happen
that continues the thing that's
significant to me though myles it was
yesterday
at six o'clock eastern time that the
cowboys
had a video conference to talk about
this recommendation
that they stay away from the off season
program the in
building on field off season program and
we haven't seen a statement from the
cowboys yet
i wonder how many of these teams for
everyone that has and we saw the
bears comment there the browns have
issued one the giants have issued one
how many teams have said thanks we
understand your point we wish you well
but we know we're gonna work out anyway
why not just work out at the team
facility that's the thing i continue to
come back to miles
you're going to work out anyway work out
at the team facility
and have insurance against an injury
that would keep you from playing this
season because if that happens
at the building you get paid if it
happens at planet fitness
you don't get paid exactly and that's
sort of the thing that i don't
necessarily understand
where they're talking about guys and
saying you know
they know how to work out on their own
we know how to get prepared a lot of
times
guys are going to go and have uh
throwing sessions i've already seen this
on social media with some guys
are already doing kind of throwing
sessions before the off season program
was even supposed to begin now that's
one thing
in phase one of the off-season program
which now is going to be this four-week
virtual period
they wouldn't be able to be on the field
anyway with a ball you know and you're
throwing with all these different
that's not allowed really during that
time as i understand it so
it becomes the then in late may right
and in june early june usually when the
ota practices are
why would you not want to be in the
facility where like you're saying mike
you have
that protection there and if you're at
that point
and a lot of these statements have been
talking about the covet 19 pandemic and
all that and how
we don't know what the safety
precautions are going to be
i think that we know that the nfl has
basically said
look we're still gonna have testing you
know and we are recommending
to we're not even recommending it's
basically for all
employees that are not players you have
to get vaccinated
so then it is incumbent on the player to
say i'm going to get
vaccinated too so i protect myself from
this virus
if you can do all of that and you know i
don't necessarily know
what the kova 19 issue is going to have
to do with it by late may
because at this point pretty much
anybody who wants to get a shot
can get a shot or at least sign up to
get a shot so it
i understand what the players are saying
but also if i'm the nfl and i know that
we collectively bargained the fact that
we were going to have an off season
program last year
i don't know why i would back down on
this
i am as supportive of player rights as
anyone in the media especially anyone
who works for the league or works for
one of the network partners
and i will say when i think the league
is it at fault
when when the players have a point and
when the players are being treated
unfairly and when the fans are lining up
behind the billionaires
instead of supporting the players that
they all think are millionaires guess
what they're all not millionaires
and so my record my record is staunch in
that regard
i think they're blowing this i think
this is a huge mistake
i think it's so obvious that this isn't
about covet 19 if it was every player
would be vaccinated
and if it is about covet 19 what's wrong
with the protocols that they negotiated
last
year for training camp
regular season and postseason what don't
they
like about the protocols
they agreed to last year
what's the problem and why aren't you
getting vaccinated it really undercuts
your argument if you're not getting
vaccinated it undercuts your argument if
you don't like the protocols that you
agreed to
and i think this is miles a combination
of different motivations different
agendas guys like jc tretter he doesn't
want one
anyway so hey we we got a pandemic we
can point to that
but next year i don't want one either
well what's your reason extra i just
don't want one
i'll i'll keep finding reasons until i
admit i just don't want one
other guys are just pissed because the
nfl always wins at the bargaining table
this is a way for them to push back a
little bit
but if you try and it collapses
what they need to understand is and i
think this is part of the
the very linear mindset that most
football players have and it can be a
very successful mindset
but at the same time there are plenty of
football players that have never seen a
brick wall they aren't ready to ram
their head into
and this idea that we're just gonna go
forward
they're not thinking what it means
if it does collapse and the nfl comes
out of this miles
saying we've proven again that this
workforce
is incapable of collective action
well the other thing too is mike i mean
you've had teams who have released
statements
that say we're not coming then we have
teams where it's
some of us are some of us are not coming
the majority of us
are not coming and you can't even
necessarily get teams to agree on those
types of things and now
since the browns obviously jc treader is
a browns player
it doesn't surprise me that the browns
as a collective have said
we're not coming to these voluntary
workouts but when they cite the coven 19
pandemic i think like you said i mean i
am in cleveland right now i signed up to
get a shot it was extremely easy i went
and i got
my first one i am on the list and i'm
getting my second one this sunday i am
very happy about it so
there are ways to be able to get
vaccinations right
and i think you know you you have a
point when you're talking about saying
it's it's not just about the coven 19
pandemic it's mostly that
they don't want this to happen anyway
and i too am very pro player i obviously
don't have the same
length of a track record as you do but
i do believe that this is not a
situation that's a polite way of calling
me old miles
i was hoping we could just move past it
it was kind of a drive by there
but like i i really do think that this
is not necessarily a fight that the
players can win because
once you get these young guys in the
draft picks that want to make
the team that are you know your sixth
your seventh round picks the undrafted
guys that are going to come in
and try to make the team you've been
saying this for the last two days right
everybody that is going to sign an
undrafted free agent is probably going
to make it very clear
that you need to be in the building and
even if they didn't make it clear the
agent is going to make it clear because
otherwise you don't have a shot at
making the team
so this i don't really know how this
ends for the players but
it just seems like it's going to be a
scatter shot thing
some guys are going to be in some guys
aren't and they don't have to be it's
voluntary but i just
i don't know that you're going to get
the real kind of collective action that
the players would need to really force
some kind of change last point on this
the timeline that the nfl has put
together is brilliant because the rookie
mini camp that happens every year
voluntary rookie mini camp
but you have draft picks undrafted free
agents and also
tryout players do you think a tryout
player who isn't worried about getting
to the 53
he's just trying to get to the 90. you
think he's not going to show up
i think that guy's going to be there
they're going to have 50 guys or more
in every training camp every facility
excuse me training camp comes later
but every facility the second week third
week of may right before
phase three of the off season program
when the doors open for those ten on
field practices
it's it's it's not going to work
they can point to specific victories a
certain player stays away or a certain
team only has 20 guys or whatever
it's not going to work it's not going to
work and they'd be better off finding a
different way
to fight this fight hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports